[Музика]
привіт, хлопці, мене звуть Віталій очко,
час для уроку англійської мови, давайте розпочнемо, і
сьогодні, як ви бачите, ми не в
класі, ми на кухні, у них
зі мною фантастичний гість, привіт, Гектор
привіт, як справи, дуже дякую за
те, що я був тут, і особливо за те, що ви
вибрали кухню так, це було, ви
знаєте, що ви – суперзірка шеф-кухаря,
і ми дуже раді бачити
вас у нашому класі, дуже дякую, що ви навчаєте в
класі  littell, це так, чи
можете ви добре вгадати тему я здогадуюсь,
їжа, я сподіваюся, що так,
так що ми сьогодні поговоримо про різні
типи їжі, тому ми
називаємо їх різними кухнями правильно.
будь легко ні я дуже нервую
ні ні, ні стрес, розслабся
добре, тому ми переглянемо деякі кухні кілька
слів і ми поговоримо про відомі
рецепти вікторина так невелика вікторина невеликий
тест я не підготував все добре, вчителю
ви можете  Вибачте, добре, тож
почнемо, коли почуємо це слово  фрукти добре,
які букви пам'ятаєте oh D
фантастично, тому вас просять, хлопці,
будь ласка, за п'ять секунд запишіть
прикметники, які починаються на ту саму
літеру,
так f oh oh і D,
а потім ви допоможете мені, так
які прикметники приходять до вас  пам'ятайте,
коли ви чуєте f будьте обережні fantastisch
свіжий фантастичний це дуже гарне слово
так фантастичний казковий
добре так свіжий фантастичний казковий так
які твої слова добре давайте підемо з O,
щоб у нас було подвійне O, просто назвіть усі
слова в цю сб ми йдемо о, якщо  ми говоримо про
о, боже мій органічний, добре зроблено, океан
– це дуже гарне слово, ви можете побачити багато
морепродуктів, ви не звичайні, звичайні
добре, мабуть, іноді, коли у нас є
час від часу, добре, тому давайте візьмемо звичайні
випадкові та органічні, а як щодо DD
різноманітні корисні чи  різноманітність і коли ви
відчуєте різницю, що смачно
правильно, ви можете сказати ще раз смачно
смачно фантастично, так що повторюйте за нами
смачно молодець, дуже дякую,
тому це були прикметники, тепер дозвольте  's
переглянути деякі іменники право на
teramo манекен добре, тому будь-які слова, і
це буде тест для вас у вас є
лише 30 секунд назвіть стільки фруктів, скільки
ви можете
фрукти 30 секунд сказав будь-який фрукт будь-який
фрукт апельсин хороший персик полуниця
виноград
[Музика]
ананас манго авокадо який є фруктовим
салатом [Музика] Я люблю банани люблю банани так,
але я віддаю перевагу манго добре,
тому я думаю, що наші студенти також люблять
яблука так
яблука також як щодо фруктів,
які насправді є овоч  фрукти молочна
служба добре, вони викликають 3ds плутається
між фруктом і овочем,
але щось читати помідор помідор так
це помідор або помідор ну це залежить як
ви це сказати помідор я кажу помідор добре,
то давайте скажемо Метту добре помідор хороший
помідор зараз  є завдання для вас, хлопці,
будь ласка, за 30 секунд запишіть якомога більше
овочів, щоб 30 секунд для
вас.
сутенер  назви один
давайте брокколі картопля цвітна капуста
[Музика]
ммм
зелена квасоля о вау, я б сказав огірок
спаржа цибуля червона цибуля, що було чудово,
п'ять дивовижно, тож де ми переглядаємо
прикметники та іменники
тепер давайте поговоримо про традиційну їжу,
бо коли ми чуємо це слово  їжа, ми
відразу уявляємо, що
в різних країнах є різні кухні,
тож мій улюблений –
італійська, чи подобається вам італійська їжа, я люблю
італійську кухню, але водночас я
народився в Колумбії, тому я, Лора, люблю
латиноамериканську кухню.
Я вчитель речі, які я можу вибрати добре,
давайте поговоримо про італійську швидко, без проблем,
звичайно, наші студенти вони люблять готувати
піцу, це легко, так, які
інгредієнти ви віддаєте перевагу для піци, як-
от начинки, так, насправді, є мої улюблені
начинки для піци  будьте, коли
ви говорите про оригінальну італійську піцу,
вони подумають про дещо, як гурукула,
а про все інше, але мені подобається
найцікавіше, а це гриби.
іони червоного болгарського перцю та курки та
томатного соусу моцарелла так, це була
б чудова піца,
я дуже любила це з дитинства
так, мені сподобалася паста, але я
люблю болоньезе мм-хм, я люблю Альберто,
добре, звідки ти знаєш, що він  сказав
Бордо, ні, чи можна сказати,
Альберто – це простий соус з часниковою
оливковою олією та невеликою кількістю петрушки,
я думаю, приготувати його дуже легко, але ми більше не називаємо його
цим ім’ям
Альберто Альберто, це італійська, добре, так що
піца – це паста – це добре  але я маленька
дівчинка,
я віддаю перевагу десертам, вибачте, добре, тому дуже
відомий італійський десерт - це, звичайно,
тірамісу, тому я приготував
для вас деякі інгредієнти, але вам потрібно
вгадати слово, щоб це було схоже на головоломку
X, тож давайте почнемо з цього
головоломка ви бачите букви, і ви також бачите
їх на екрані, тому спробуйте
вгадати слова чи знаєте ви слово
какао так ми кажемо какао О, ми кажемо какао
добре
так ми пишемо какао Coco Coco скажемо
ще раз какао і какао добре так  тепер
це зроблено, давайте  номер другий, чи можете ви
вгадати слово, боже, який
сир нам потрібен для тірамісу,
якщо ви хочете зробити оригінальний
оригінал, це маскарпоне так, але якщо
іноді ви можете визначити маскарпоне,
то є кілька дуже варіантів, які ви
можете замінити  чи плавлений сир
добре, ви можете замінити його на це, і якщо
насправді ваш бюджет настільки низький, що
ви не можете знайти вершковий сир тут, в
Україні, я знайшов дуже хороший варіант
, коли ви обробляєте дуже добре, що крутите
мм-хм і перемішуєте його  з жирними вершками
з виглядом на одну версію для мене мм-хм,
то дозвольте мені сказати це українською для вас
єшива назва нуль маскарпоне ніколи
Маркус хвилину а О бутик у кремовій
сироватці так, звісно, це ціла майя ви
е, як тісто для піци janeski ал
багато солоності суміш якийсь
жахливий Табіш дайте пакет Будда
доса їй ні добре, ви просто каші,
і стільки скажіть так, тож давайте з
номером три подивіться на це, що
це, ви можете вгадати слова
так цукор  цукор Брава, ти багато
додаєш так, це мій улюблений світ, коли мої
учні відмінно виступають я кажу браво,
мабуть, через тебе добре, давайте перейдемо
до наступного, це так важко
так, добре, а останній подивіться,
що у нас тут  дуже цікаво,
тому що насправді змішання
букв робить таку кількість слів
іспанською мовою, я знаю, що це кава кава сер
тірамісу кава хм,
я збираюся їсти тірамісу і пити
каву моя чи потрібна нам кава насправді не
одна з характеристик
Тірамісу має таку кислотність
сиру, який використовується також і
солодкий цукор, але дуже цікаво, що
він має гірку дію, а гірку
дію надає кава,
і що ви робите, це є кілька маленьких
печива  що ви називаєте перевагою так або
ladyfers, що ви замочуєте їх у
суміші кави та масали, яка є
португальським вином, я добре бачу, чи
буде добре для дітей, якщо вони просто
змочують пальчики в каві
ab  безперечно просто кава, але вам не
потрібно дозволяти їм сидіти всередині
кави, ви просто дайте жінці пальчик
і чашку кави, і ви просто робите це, і
це все лише для того, щоб трохи
намочити її зовні, так що пам'ятайте,
як  це дуже швидко, добре, тому ми говорили
про італійську їжу, але коли діти
готують, грецький салат
для них надзвичайно популярний, тому що це легко,
і всі інгредієнти, які у нас
є, ми можемо легко знайти їх в Україні,
абсолютно правдиві, і це один із найкращих.
найпопулярніші салати в усьому світі,
тому що це дуже легко
, це здорово, кожен може знайти весь
цей процес у будь-якій країні
світу так, які інгредієнти
давайте
помідори помідори помідори огірок добре червона
цибуля добре червоний болгарський перець або насправді
це спочатку  з зеленим зеленим
болгарським перцем і сиром фета хороший сир
фета для гарніру до
соусу мм-хм, які ви використовуєте, люди
ускладнюються з цими джерелами, але
насправді в Греції вони роблять дуже  просто
, це просто оливкова олія, трохи
червоного винного оцту та Орегон Орегон о
так, а як щодо оливки каламата так
для мене
грецький салат, це перш за все,
ви їсте з сиром фета та оливками,
насправді так, оливки каламата
іноді бувають  це трохи дорого,
але ви можете замінити його будь-якими іншими
оливками, які у вас є під рукою,
я бачу, і знову ж таки, якщо у вас немає
найстаріших, це нормально, ви можете просто пропустити це
добре, для мене вони найбільше поєднуються з
овочами та сиром фета
важливо добре, готовий до ще одного
тесту, це буде тест пам'яті,
так що це всі інгредієнти
грецьких салатів, що це за помідор, добре,
це буде тут перший, а
потім другий, ви порівняйте, так що ми маємо
помідор і огірок помідор  і огірок
добре, ми йдемо далі, ви згадали, що
це не червоний, добре, тому ми повинні зробити
помідор огірок цибуля коза молодець
що це я погано малюю я
вчитель англійської, тому що вона виглядає
трохи  як вишня, вибачте, це
добре
каламата каламата добре так ще раз
помідор огірок цибуля і кілометр
добре так
вибачте я не художник
нехай це буде Орегон о добре Орегон о,
скажімо, ми захоплюємо слова з вмісту
так томат томат огірок цибуля
каламата  оливки фета та Орегон о,
і основні частини, найважливіші частини
є червоний винний оцет оливкова олія оливкова
олія
давайте оливкова олія О, який
оцет, це буде лимонний сік так,
давайте з основними інгредієнтами
для дітей добре,
мабуть, мама збирається  до або гастрономів
вони додадуть ще трохи ванілі,
тож давайте переглянемо помідор огірок цибуля
каламата оливки сир фета сир орегано
оливкова олія і трохи оцту, чи
можете ви знову сказати, будь ласка, помідор огірок
цибуля каламата оливки фета або ігано
оливкова олія і трохи  так, добре,
давайте як цей помідор огірок цибульний
хліб каламата все це сир фета
орегано, оливкова олія і
трохи оцту, добре, тепер я ховаю помідор, а
вони ховають  оливкова олія ви не можете
побачити картинку давайте помідори огірок червона
цибуля каламата оливки фета сир
орегано і оливкова олія і
трохи фантастичного зараз я приховаю всі малюнки,
тож давайте зачекаємо, поки учні скажуть, що у
вас є 10 секунд, назвіть слова
фантастично зараз на місці помідор
огірок червона цибуля каламата оливки
сир фета орегано і оливкова олія і
трохи червоного винного оцту
дякую дуже дай п'ять Браво це
дивовижно, це було дуже швидко, і я можу сказати,
що ваша пам'ять дійсно хороша  добре, тому
ми обговорювали італійську їжу,
коли ми говоримо про грецьку їжу, коли ми говоримо про дітей, вони
люблять курячі булочки донер кебап, це також
їх улюблений,
я думаю, що це родом із Туреччини,
як ви думаєте, так, насправді, було
досить популярно в усі старі часи
Османська імперія тощо, але Туреччина
стала відомою в усьому світі тим, що Джордж
подарував одну з найсмачніших ми маємо
схожу, скажімо, схожу страву в
різних країнах, наприклад, оскільки ми
т  Говорять про грецькі салати в Греції, у них
також є донер кебап, який
називається дерас, добре, чи можете ви
придумати щось з інших країн, наприклад,
тако, наприклад, це не те саме,
є кесадільї, добре, це також з
коржиками та м'ясом
наприклад, є також класичний
лула-кебаб добре, який трохи
схожий, але не є рецептом
донора. мм-хм,
є латиноамериканська арепа Регіна
, а також найпопулярніша в
Колумбії, Венесуела, яка готується з
коржів  з кукурудзяного борошна, а також з
різними видами м'яса всередині, так що
це як наш тип PITA
Мені подобається, що в Туреччині є лаваш, у
нас є арепа, ну, це дуже
цікаво, а як щодо рулету з куркою, я
пам'ятаю, що  ми можемо легко знайти це в
McDonald's, чи ви думаєте, що це
щось на кшталт американського насправді
, коли ви говорите про
всіх цих донорів і все, що
ви можете знайти їх не тільки з баранини чи
[Музика]
телятина, але ви можете знайти їх також з
курки, так що насправді ви можете побачити
багато курки в цьому елементі, який
вони готують на грилі, і вони кладуть його
в лаваш, навіть якщо цей курячий рулет,
тому що вони продають його в McDonald
saranghae  його просто американізовано,
але
спочатку його немає, я бачу, що це не
так, тож давайте з турецьким донером
кебаб добре, так що зараз це буде тест на
аудіювання, тому ми вже
перевірили ваш зір, ми вже
перевірили вашу пам'ять, тепер це  час перевірити
свої вуха добре, так що ви збираєтеся
послухати мене, я дам вам інструкції або
вказівки, як приготувати донер кебаб, але
є помилка добре, тому неправильне слово
не помилка в рецепті, а
неправильне слово спробуйте вловити  це і змінити
добре, так що готовий номер один у великій
рогатій худобі об'єднайте лампу яйце часник і деякі
трави я збираюся прочитати це ще раз у великій
рогатій худобі з'єднайте ягняче яйце часник і трави,
як ви думаєте, що тут неправильне слово
я ніколи не буду вас ставити  wo  я ніколи не
кладу яйце, але послухай мене у великій
рогатій худобі, що таке велика рогата худоба, худоба,
велика рогата худоба, це як для дитини на
сковороді, о так, спочатку це було б
у великій мисці, об'єднайте всі інгредієнти,
добре, давайте з номером два  помістіть
суміш у каструлю і готуйте 30 годин
на повітрі, о боже мій, це легко, ні
30 годин, але 30 хвилин, так, це
було б добре, тому послухайте, чи є правильний
, помістіть суміш у каструлю і
готуйте 30 хвилин  в духовці
добре зараз номер 3 я думаю це
найскладніше готове добре нарізати донер
кебаб якомога дрібніше і
подавати теплим з лавашом і салатом
знову
нарізати м'ясо донер шашлик якомога дрібніше
і подати теплий лаваш  і
Сал,
тепер вам потрібно заповнити лаваш
добре, це один з можливих, а як
щодо першої інструкції слухати відбивну
О, діти наріжте це, вам просто
потрібно нарізати так точно так, щоб ви нарізали
середину, то яка різниця між
відбивною та скибкою  буде ac  нарешті нарізати Джордж,
ти можеш робити це дуже-дуже
маленькими шматочками, чесно кажучи, я сказав, що ти
просто добре нарізаєш, мм-хм, тому поліція на її
ім'я ключовий екіпаж Ленка Маточкин про choppa dipnetting
добре, ми також можемо сказати кубик у кубах добре
насправді, коли ви кажете в  кухня,
коли ви кажете відбивну, це видно так,
щоб не складати або три кути або куби,
це все як відбивна, як добре, вона
повинна бути маленькою, але не має значення,
яка форма, якщо ви хочете сказати, що ви
хочете куби  тому вам потрібно сказати, що ви повинні
нарізати його кубиками, добре, коли шеф-кухар
дуже молодий на кухні, є
дуже гарна фраза, коли вам потрібно рухатися
швидко, ви кажете добре, тому я також використовую
фразу cut це просто загальне слово
або  щось інше, так нарізане нарізане
та порізане, порізане, порізане, ми використовуємо його в основному, вам
потрібно, коли ви кажете, якщо я скажу чотири,
це давайте подумаємо, у нас є огірок,
добре, якщо я скажу вам, папуга наріжте цей
огірок, ваше наступне запитання буде так,
тому я  потрібно дати додаткову
інструкцію так  карат кубиками або
морква трикутниками або розрізати її на півроку,
розрізати навпіл добре, тому якщо я скажу розрізати,
можливо, ти порізав, але тоді я збирався
сказати, що ти порізав це неправильно,
о мій Боже, ти скажеш те, що
ніколи не говорив мені  як розрізати
так, іноді ми робимо це так само,
як і вчителі, ми говоримо, виконуйте вправу
вчитель, як виконувати цю вправу, дайте нам
додаткові інструкції, це правильно,
тому використовуйте слово "скибочка" або "нарізати", я
думаю, це краще так, добре  Тож давайте
переглянемо ми говорили про їжу, що
були прикметниками, усі цілі.
Добре, якщо ви думаєте про свіжий, свіжий,
а також на все, що ми мали органічну користь для D у
нас було смачно смачно так, це
мій улюблений варіант смачного ммм,
а також коли ви  як щось, що ти можеш
сказати ммм, це смачно, і коли тобі це не
подобається, що ти кажеш ммм як як о,
Кім, людина, ти щойно назвав
себе і скажи добре, якщо ти в
ресторані, так, але ти не можеш цього сказати
твоїй мами ні, я просто буду шанувальником
ніколи  те, що твоя мама подає
тобі на столі, ти маєш з'їсти це так,
ти повинен лизнути свою тарілку, це було б
чудово,
тому нашою попередньою темою був спорт, і ми
говорили про домашній стиль життя, так
здорова їжа, яка б це була
ммм кількість у списку  жирний мм-хм
найкраща їжа nofas добре ні фаст-
фуд перше, що я знаю, якщо у вас є, наприклад,
якщо ви готуєте свій грецький салат, про який
ми говорили, зробіть заправку
самі, якщо всі вони з
орегано з оцтом  трохи
солі, трохи перцю,
іноді люди просто купують цей соус, який уже
приготований, ага, ця ковбаса містить цукор
, це ціла купа плюсів, які
не корисні для вашого здоров’я,
тому вам краще займатися своїми справами
вдома.  Найкращий спосіб підтримувати здоровий спосіб життя
- це те, що ви готуєте самі,
ага, насправді,
навіть коли ви порівнюєте, скажімо,
гамбургер із
харчової мережі чи щось домашнє,
чого ви не дбаєте про
батька  хінг, це
ще здоровіше, це гарна ідея: готувати
гамбургери сам, і я буду струнким
, це те, що я роблю,
я люблю гамбургери, я людина, тому я
люблю дуже гарне слово, але я
все
роблю сам  Я купую його з
дуже невеликим вмістом жиру, потім я подрібнюю їх
сам, а потім перемішую все, щоб я знав,
що всередині, я бачу, тому він здоровий,
молодець, тому, хлопці, наступний урок
буде уроком проекту, і ми будемо  поговоримо
про улюблені рецепти та як
їх приготувати, тож перший — тірамісу,
другий — грецький салат, грецький
салат, а номер 3 — це був
кебаб «Донер», так,
проголосуйте за страву, яку ви
хотіли б обговорити, і  приготуй, і ми
обговоримо це тут, у класі на
кухні, тому я чую, як у міфах дзвонить дзвінок про
те, що нам потрібно зупинитися в останній раз,
і я хотів більше гаразд, тому сподіваюся, що
ми знову побачимо вас у нашій школі,
щиро дякую  так багато до побачення
[Музика]
ти